[Music]
the largest wildfire in California
history the deadly Mendocino complex
fire was finally fully contained this
week it started in July wildfires have
burned about 7.3 million acres across
the u.s. so far this year that compares
to an average of more than 5.8 million
acres but the equivalent period over the
last 10 years scientists are trying to
unlock the secrets of how fires spread
in hopes of keeping them away from
people and property as Carter Evans
reports they're adding new tools to
understand a growing threat fire
tornadoes at the u.s. forest fire lab in
Montana they're fighting fires by
lighting fires we're understanding all
the processes that go into understanding
how a fire spreads okay let's check it
out research Forester mark Finney and
his team have spent decades building a
series of demonstrations that replicate
real-world fire conditions out in the
wild 10 camera has been there mounted
from every different angle we do that
just for documentation but we also take
measurements off of those cameras do you
know how fire spreads well we're getting
there our intention is to understand the
physical processes that lead to
different kinds of fire behaviors and in
order to do that we have to design
experiments that can scale all the way
up to the field scale but in the last
few years most firefighters have told us
that scale is growing larger than
anything they've seen before and this
past July the world watched something
most of us have never witnessed a fire
tornado
this massive funnel of smoke and flames
outside Redding California was about a
thousand feet wide and reached wind
speeds of 165 miles per hour equivalent
to an ef3 tornado there were vehicles
that were rolled and moved there were
large powerline towers that were torn
off the base and actually blown through
the air you've studied this stuff for a
long time have you ever seen anything
like that no I have not so it's already
starting the rotation yep you can see
wow that's pretty decent one there
mechanical engineer Jason fourth offers
specializes in fire tornadoes also known
as fire whirls as the hot air above the
fire accelerates vertically it actually
stretches the air in the already
rotating air spins it up into these
really really tight world and high wind
speeds and the fire is essentially
fueling this phenomenon that's all right
we've seen these things last over an
hour out in the real world what are you
learning here about them in the lab we
know enough to understand some of the
ingredients that cause fire whirls but
we're not too close to being able to
predict actually when and where they
will occur out on the ground
fourth offer says fire tornadoes like
this recent one in Canada that sucked a
hose up into its vortex are actually not
uncommon occurrences smaller versions
happen on almost every major fire
they're usually just far away from
populated areas and TV cameras it seems
like these fires are getting bigger and
bigger every year should we expect to
see more fire tornadoes yeah I would say
just because it seems like we're having
more intense fires and so the fire
tornadoes sort of correlate with that
it's pretty amazing just to sit here and
watch this form before your eyes and
that makes the research they're doing
here in Montana even more critical to
protecting property and saving lives for
CBS this morning Carter Evans Missoula
Montana
it's beautiful watching the lab that
picture was just terrifying
at least you know they're tracking it
and trying to figure out what we can do
somebody's on top of it